الكشف عن تفسيرات جديده لظاهره دوران
الاغنام المريبه ظهور علامات الشيخوخه على
مراهقين عايشوا اغلاقات كورونا وسوبر
كمبيوتر يصدم بتوقعاته ليونيل ميسي
وكريستيانو رونالدو هذه الاخبار وغيره
نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
تثير حيره العلماء حول العالم خصوصا بعد
ظهورها في الاردن عقب مشاهدتها لاول مره
داخل حظيره في الصين علماء في جامعه
بريطانيه حاولوا تفسيرا ظاهره المريبه
قائلين ان بقاء الاغنام في الحظيره لفترات
طويله قد يؤدي بها لهذا السلوك فيما اوضحت
وزاره الاردنيه
قد تؤدي لهذا السلوك الغريب
في بحث جديد شكل صدمه لدى الكثيرين كشف
باحثون ان ادمغت المراهقين الذين عايشوا
عمليات الاغلاق المرتبطه بفيروس كورونا
ظهرت عليهم علامات الشيخوخه المبكره البحث
الذي نشرته صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه وتم
اجراؤه في امريكا على عشرات المتطوعين وجد
فيه الباحثون ان التغيرات الجسديه في
الدماغ التي حدثت خلال فتره المراهقه مثل
ترقق القشره ونمو اللوز كانت اكبر في فتره
ما بعد الاخلاق مقارنه بما قبل الجائحه
مما يشير الى تسريع مثل هذه العمليات او
بعباره اخرى تقدمت ادمنتهم بشكل اسرع
بعد ورود تقارير افادت بان جسمه لم يعد
يستجب للعلاج الكيميائي اكد اسطوره كره
القدم البرازيلي بيليه المتواجد في
المستشفى من اجل العلاج انه يشعر بالقوه
والامل وفي بيان على انستغرام طلب بيليه
من محبيه ومتابعيها التحلي بالهدوء
والايجابيات قائلا انه قوي ولديه الكثير
من الامل وانه يتابع علاجه كالمعتاد في ما
كانت صحيفه فولها البرازيليه كشفت ان
اسطوره كره القدم ادخل العنايه المخففه
مشيره الى انه لم يعد يستجيب للعلاج
الكيميائي من سرطان القولون الذي يعاني
منه
الى اخبار المونديال هذه المره حيث صدم
سوبر كمبيوتر الذي يعتمد على مزيج من
التوقعات والتحليلات الرقميه صدمه ليونيل
ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو في كاس العالم
وفقا لسوبر كمبيوتر فان البرازيل هي من
ستحصد لقب المونديال حيث ستتجاوز كوريا
الجنوبيه ثم ثم النهائي في ثمن نهائي ثم
اليابان في ربع النهائي وبعدهما الارجنتين
في المربع الذهبي قبل ان تجرد فرنسا من
لقبها في النهايه فيما كانت توقعات سوبر
كمبيوتر في اول مباراتين بالدور ثمن
النهائي صائبه حيث مرشحها هولندا لتجاوز
عقبه امريكا والارجنتين للتاهل على حساب
استراليا وهو ما حصل فعلا
وفي خبرنا الاخير قررت محكمه امريكيه
تعويضه طالبتين توامتين اتهمتا بالغش في
احد الاختبارات بمبلغ مليون ونصف مليون
دولار بعدما اكدت هيئه المحلفين ان تطابق
اجاباتهما طبيعي بحكم الصله الجينيه بين
التوامتين مصدر في موقع انسايدر اوضح ان
الاختين كيله وكيلي بينجام تعرضتها للكثير
من المواقف الصعبه وتشويه السمعه لان
جامعتهما الطبيه في صوت كارولينا وصافتهما
بالغشاشتين قائلتين ان ادرجتان الدراجات
المماثله التي حصلت عليها في الامتحان
كانت اكثر من مجرد مصادفه فيما اشار
الموقع الى ان الفتاتين ربحتان القضيه بعد
نحوي ست سنوات من رفعها وحرمانها من دراسه
الطب